nächste Woche wird Olaf Scholz Rip
Erdogan die Hand schütteln müssen dem
Präsidenten der mit uns tatsächlich
einen Abkommen abgeschlossen hat und 3,5
Millionen syer aufgenommen hat mit der
EU nicht nur mit Deutschland der auf der
anderen Seite aber die Hamas für eine
Befreiungsarmee hält und das
Existenzrecht Israels
anzweifelt sind das genau diese
Kompromisse diese unendlichen dreckigen
Geschäfte die wir machen müssen wenn wir
etwas an diesen Zahlen ändern wollen ich
gehe davon aus dass Olaf Scholz in den
Gesprächen mit Herrn Erdogan wirklich
auch klartex in in dieser Hinsicht redet
das ist absurd das muss man sagen
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir ein
Interesse daran dass wir mit der Türkei
im Gespräch bleiben auch das ist ja
offenkundig
das ist wie bei vielen anderen
internationalen Fragen auch wir können
uns leider nicht aussuchen in welchen
Fällen in welchen Ländern wir regiert
sondern da muss man die Dinge so nehmen
wie sie sind